hi guys the tldw version is monoliths
are okay
especially in a serverless managed
runtime environment
now i work as a consultant in the it
industry
and on the tip of the tongues of a lot
of consultants is microservices and i've
been burned by microservices
i'm having to pick up the pieces from
microservices so this is my video
saying
don't use microservices basically i mean
just don't fall into the trap
and it's a very easy trap to fall into
because like i'm i'm a you know me i'm a
unix plan i'm sort of freak
and
it sounds very attractive that things
are split apart and things are kind of
composable you know
mapping what i know to
you know the web and all that stuff but
it doesn't map well
you don't want to distribute a system
you want a monolith
you don't have to coordinate everything
you don't want multiple connections to
your database you don't want
the potential
crazy issues that you can get with
microservices like it's really hard to
debug
you know a workflow going touching a
couple of microservices it's really hard
so i wrote a blog about it
i would love your feedback below right
so i mean here's a typical
this is like a simple case you know
there's some sort of flow that a
purchase flow where where there is some
authentication service there's maybe a
payment service and then there's a
service to actually provide the service
so all in all i don't know we have it
you have to add this up right
it it can typically be
be quite slow
that's another thing with microservices
is that
is that you know you're only as strong
as your weakest link and if something is
taking slow then you have to like you
know debug it
you have to monitor it
i think a lot of companies think oh i
have my microservice i can map it to a
department and things like this but you
need some some top level management here
you need to make sure things are
coordinated you need to make sure that
these endpoints are fast because if any
one of them slow the whole thing becomes
slow and then and then
a lot of thing people don't assume like
the best case scenario but like you know
it's very easy for any one of these
requests to time out and then you have
to think about your fallbacks and things
like this
getting everyone to
do the same error handling or or for
other people to know that you are
handling it's it's such a tricky
proposition seriously
so anyway this is what i typically see
you know something that's just taking a
whole bunch of seconds and it's you know
unreliable error-prone all the rest of
it
so
how can we fix this
you could introduce like a queue
but then it depends like where you
introduce the queue it gets a bit tricky
um and then you have to manage the dead
letter queue where things just didn't
work out at all
and that's usually buried in some other
obscure log file that no one looks at
okay we can make
the we could completely redo the this
this purchase api so that becomes
asynchronous so we've gone from like
rest to asynchronous there's no real
good standardized way of expressing an
asynchronized asynchronous api in my
experience
so when people say oh let's just make
the synchronous api asynchronous this is
not like javascript
this is
this becomes a lot tricky you have to
like
send the job and then perhaps get some i
don't know job id and then you're
supposed to check on the job until it's
done it's not easy
it's seriously not easy i mentioned
monitoring yeah you can instrument apis
with like prometheus have like a slash
metrics endpoint gather all up in
prometheus have a grafana dashboard
drill into which is a problematic api
and things like this
but there's a lot going on there it's
it's really non-trivial to do this you
need you know there's lots of little you
know what's an error what is an error
this uh you know
defining the
the slos and all the stuff it's it's a
lot of bureaucracy
if it was all just in the monolith this
would be so much more manageable
caching more caching is hard and it can
lead to all sorts of problems
and then yeah like another typical
solutions yeah let's just make that the
api
it impotent so that it can be retried or
something like this
that's that's tricky because then that
api should maintain some sort of state
so that it knows
what has been happening
at least that's the way i've interpreted
it in the past so yeah i've
i've rebutted these things here again in
text
and it can easily get more complicated
as i've tried to like draw here and to
conclude distribution the systems are
really hard so in this particular case
when i'm picking up the pieces of
microservices
where these constant timeouts and
everything's unreliable
i'm going to recommend that they
i know they're capable of the i'm going
to just recommend that they have to have
a budget
and make sure that the apis are faster
and less error prone
to over to to improve their their
current system but i would love to hear
from you guys like
is there a better approach that have
have i missed out some sort of trick
manage microservices have i missed
something
i'd love to hear about your experiences
i mean like like ah
i mean this is definitely a problem i
mean aws wrote a blog just describing
these problems and and solutions which i
think is just
just more complicated than
than just making the apis
uh faster
so
yeah that's my
that's my consultant advice to my to my
clients now
don't use microservices go for monolith
and if you do have microservices you've
got to start managing them really well
with prometheus
link in the description for one of my
prometheus projects but otherwise guys
i'd love to hear your your take on this
microsoft madness
comments below bye guys